to um call division three work session
uh into um operation
so as chair of the division three of the
house finance committee i find that due
to the state of emergency and you're
recording that
state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of covet 19
pandemic in accordance with the
governor's emergency order number 12.
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
is extended this public body is
authorized to meet electronically
please note that there is no physical
location to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
which was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i'm confirming
that we are providing public access to
the meeting
by telephone and by zoom
the committee is using zoom for this
remote meeting all members of the
committee and the staff of state
agencies with agenda items have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during the meeting through this platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously watch and or listen to
the meeting on zoom or phone
following the directions and links
provided in the house calendar starting
with house
calendar 8 running through i think 16 is
the most current
all of those are on the general court
website
we have previously given notice to the
public of the necessary information for
accessing the meeting telephonically
those instructions as i said are in the
house calendar
we are providing the public with a way
to
alert us should there be problems with
access
so we would ask you to email
fiscal f i s c a l at
l e g dot state dot nh dot u
s if you're having problems and if
you're having problems
we will adjourn the meeting and
reschedule please note that all the
votes that we take
by roll call and mr clerk if you're
ready let's start the meeting by
taking a roll call attendance when each
member states their presence
please also state if there's anyone in
the room with you during the meeting
and this is required under right to know
representative president home alone in
my home office
representative weiler employment
kingston others in the house i'm alone
in this room
representative bean i'm home at my home
in guilford and
my wife is in and out of the house
wallner home in concord and my husband
is in the house
representative nordgren representative
and i'm in my dining room in hanover and
i'm alone
representative rogers catherine rogers
i'm in concord in my apartment with my
dog romeo
representative edwards i'm in my home
office in auburn
and my wife and daughter are in the
house but um
my door is shut all members present
all right thank you um so
uh mr ripple would you uh share the
screen
showing the email the one that says the
last
the last five things tomorrow sure
okay first i want to thank
representative rogers for reaching out
to me
i thought i thought i learned a nice
phrase about
the final four being the end of march
madness but
as it turned out we had five things so
so thank you representative rogers for
catching that and letting me know
uh so uh as a result of that we
definitely will be talking about
hb1 around family planning today
um and then we have a pretty significant
i imagine kind of a long conversation on
the sununu
center and um i
uh that mr ripple sent out an email that
had
i think nine attachments to it and plus
i would
encourage you to take a look at uh this
maura o'neal's email that
with a report in it that i sent
separately
i think we need to be familiar with all
of those so that we can discuss them
well this afternoon and make some
decisions
i want to lock down where we stand on
sysc
and i would ask representative weiler
and representative waller
since you have so much experience in
this area
i would i would uh be willing at that
point to turn the chair
over to you representative weiler to let
you lead that part of the discussion
is that you're nodding your head i think
that's okay right
yes okay so so we'll talk about that
last
because that's such a significant piece
uh then we have uh two back of the
budget votes
uh we reviewed them yesterday so
hopefully we're ready to vote on them
today i think we are
and then we voted on out in hb2
related to the adt transfers
to the community to coordinate care but
as we went to hb1 representative
walner pointed out that to see the whole
budget before we vote on that separate
item
so at this point hopefully we're up to
speed and we can
look at the hp1 impact and make a
decision on that
uh and then dhhs requested some budget
line
changes that went out uh i apologize
because i think i've uh accidentally sat
on that issue
since about nine or ten days ago when uh
when the
department sent it to us um and as
i look at it and i've talked a little
bit to mr ripple and gotten some
secondary
impact from ms rounds uh it it seems
like
one through 19 are probably not
particularly controversial they tend to
um weigh each other out net each other
out item 20
is pretty significant but we were
briefed on it
when we heard the new hampshire
hospitals uh presentation
there's one particular slide mr ripple
when we get to that will you be able to
show that one slide were you able to
find it in the new hampshire hospital
presentation
um i don't have enough but i can find it
now yeah we won't be talking about
any of these i don't well maybe we could
okay
so so those are the five items for today
i think that if we do those five
we've done everything and we're done
uh except for doing our finance
committee work
next week and so this is really getting
to be the last
call uh if if if you think we're missing
something if you want another discussion
on something
please let me know because this is
really
you know the very last minute as they
say
so so um mr ripple i do have a question
for you
um on once we go through these
conversations
i think that's going to generate
a an update to that
two those two summary documents you did
the uh you know the two i believe the
one with the line item details
showing changes from hp one and two
and then the other one that just
summarizes the general
impact of the of them both do
do we do you need to produce those and
have a vote on those
also or if we just decide these
incremental things are we good
you're on mute sir
sorry the incremental votes are enough
you don't need to vote on the summary
documents
if you are interested in those documents
now i do have updated versions
reflecting what you did yesterday
well why don't you hang on to them
because i think we're going to have to
update them again based on today and so
i don't i don't see a need to you know
move copies around that are
going to be out of date so shortly
um representative weiler your hand is up
sir
yes i get some updated uh revenue from
uh from uh chris in the
lba and he says that this is
this is an amendment to hb1 it's
official
i said what about the fact we have this
official thing and he said well
according to his reading get anything
official from
from ways and means whether it's
approved by the house or not
the uh he thinks that the rules allow us
to update things
as we get them but this is kind of late
late in the system it's like almost 90
million in the first year and 74 million
in the second year
uh so you know i think those
those are better done in the senate if
we're gonna we could
there's things we really want to
prioritize i think we could add some
things back in but
this is kind of late in the game this
these would take a couple of days to go
through all this stuff
so um
i'm going to meet at noon with the
speaker and see what he thinks but
to me this is kind of late in the game
yes yes sir could you clarify
if those additions are off of the
existing ways and means estimate
or off of the estimates the governor
used
uh these are off of the existing ways
and means
so that you know they're not off the
governor so obviously they're they're
the additions
to the green sheet so
if we just accepted them and mr ripple
rolled them
into our summary documents
um wouldn't that just show um
i'm not sure what we call that the
difference between revenues and expenses
wouldn't that just show a higher
margin yeah i guess it would show a
greater margin we could say yeah
recommend it to go to the
rainy day fund for all of that
i mean we've done that we pared down
what we think is important and not in
the
health and human services which was our
task
and then at the last minute with with
more revenue
i don't think it's a fair game yes sir i
i agree that i don't think we should be
chasing
the opportunity to spend it at this
point because we're wrapping up but
miss mister uh we'll come i'll come to
you in just a second representative
i want to see what mr ripple had to say
i was just going to say that that's not
anything you need to do in division
three that's more of a full committee
thing
ah brilliant
thank you that's that's the insight we
hope
for um all right representative wallner
do you have a
question ma'am yes um
representative weiler yesterday i
thought what you referred to or
yeah yesterday i guess it was 127
million dollars so
now it's 164 million dollars over
the ways and means estimates
that's that's the way it adds up the
table
that chris chase sent me to to accept
he headed in a in a rather unusual form
he should
compared with what we got on the green
sheet it shows total general fund
and then it shows education fund and i
wrote back to him and said why are the
numbers so different he said well you
failed to add
the education trust fund but he's got
fiscal year 2022 in fiscal year 23 and
two columns and the columns below that
he's got fiscal year 2018 in fiscal year
so how was i to know that i'm supposed
to add those
figures with the education trust fund
into the ones above
to get the real total which i did
so it's and the figures have changed a
bit
from what we discussed so now it's it's
like 163.9 or 164 million which is more
than
the original thing it would still be
roughly about 50 of
um well let's see yeah
so it'd be about 90 above the uh
163 yeah so anyway that's
it's it's going to be more than what
what the governor's was
since this issue is a great issue but
it's outside of the scope of division
three
right can we wrap this up representative
i don't want to stop you from talking
more though
well i i just wondered if uh
representative weiler
if i could get that um
that that in a corrective form
okay from chris to everybody okay
great thank you i would i would love to
see that okay thank you
thank you so
uh let's go to the oldest first on this
miss ripple
uh let's go to that 200k add to hp1
i'm taking you out of your anticipated
sequence i bet
that's okay i have it up here
i'm gonna free shut my door and tell the
dog to quit working
i don't know if you guys can hear that
or not but that dog
has a really high pitched bark pierces
okay so um you may recall this
was originally in one of the house bills
that we voted on
uh your your hand is up represent walnut
do you have a question or is that
no it's lord thank you so
so this was a house bill 2 item that
simply showed a 200
000 um reservation of funds to
support the admissions dispositions and
transfers
transactions that help coordinate
community care
as our clients around the state
uh and because that was for ongoing
operations and
sort of came a little late uh in the in
the
governor's budget process it got put
into hb1
so because that is an ongoing expense
we voted to take it out of hp2 and put
it
back into hb1 and as we do that
hb1 reflects
the 600 000 match that goes along with
that 200
000 and then in the process of
looking into this um uh one
one of our state employees noticed that
there was an eight hundred and four
dollar
um typo uh and so she's using this
opportunity to clean up
the typo and get the document more
precise
so so the effect on this is that we
would
add the 200 000 to the general funds
because it's an operating expense
we'd add the 600 000 to the federal
total because we'd be eligible for a
three to one match apparently and that
would add 800
000 overall as an increase
without really looking at the 804
typo so that's
that's what we're doing is there is
there any conversation about this
it's representative irfan we had talked
briefly about this i can't see if he's
i'm here yet you have any any thoughts
on this sir
i think we should do it
so um i gotta fix
my zoom box so i can see everyone give
me a second i'm distracted
and my understanding is we agreed that
the funding the the
what we were spending the money on was
worthwhile the
the adt system as you described it hello
thank you sir um
could you could you mute yeah there you
go so representative walner
um you i think you wanted more time just
because it was the right thing to do
not that you had an issue with this but
but i don't know
no issue i'm fine okay
all right so do you need a vote on this
mr ripple
or yes i think voting on this would be
good
is there an amendment number there's no
amendment number since it's only a
change to the numbers in house bill 1.
you could just take a motion to vote on
the recommended changes to account 59-52
removed second
being moved and seconded is there any
discussion
not seeing any discussion uh would the
clerk take a role please
in favor of the motion to move the money
uh representative earth
yes representative weiler votes yes
representative bean
yes representative walner
uh yes
yes representative rogers
yes representative edwards
yes mr chair the vote is 7-0
thank you um so
i would like us to consider the hb1
around family planning there was some
discussion about that yesterday i
believe representative
irf and rogers have gotten together
twice to bounce things around and
ms rounds participated a little bit this
morning
so so um in that
a proposal has come forth that i'd like
to
share and and i understand
representative rogers you have an
additional
point of view that you'd like us to
consider for hb1 family planning
i would still like to offer the
amendment that i offered yesterday which
um has money that's in excess of the
match but has money
that would fill the gap for the clinics
that in fact
will not be receiving um federal monies
until the um
the federal gap the federal
gag order is lifted and it will take
approximately nine months for that money
to come through
so the amendment that i have would um
help fill that gap
with general funds um until the
beginning of the year so that they would
be able to
get do that have
words around that is that an hb2 is that
a footnote is that something
it's an amendment house bill one it's
the one that yesterday i had offered i
believe
represent representative ripple has that
available
um since it's the same one we had
yesterday
okay so what you want to do
will you want to discuss the wording of
the footnote or will you want to discuss
the numbers
in the accounts it's not a footnote it's
an amendment
to the house bill one and it simply
changes the um
amount of money that's in there
okay so so mr ripple if we could start
with uh hb1 that you put together for me
based on
sure hold on one second here
so let's just scroll down to the general
funds line
okay and talk about this um so mr ripple
as i'm seeing the 811
805 in the in the first cell of the
general fund
is that is that precisely the amount
that was in the governor's budget
because i i i'm remembering eight twelve
thousand
so i think this is the exact number
okay that's the precise number okay
that's all right i i had it in my head
as a
as a rounding thing um okay so
um
so two years ago the in the fy 1819
budget the general funds
uh funded family lines
at about 596 000 a year
596. and then the trump administration
happened
and there were you know moves and
counter moves
during uh his administration on
on acceptance and movement of federal
money and
supplementing and backfilling okay so
that's that's behind us
um so so what this proposal
does is it says family planning is
important to the state
we want to go from 596 000 that was
being spent
in fy 19
we want to accept the governor's budget
at 812
or 811 805 to be more precise
that was the governor's recommendation
on top of that because we voted on hb2
yesterday to uh require the physical
and financial separation
of family planning counseling from
other medical procedures
we have we can anticipate the
probability or possibility
that the state is going to have to go
get
new vendors so that there isn't
a gap in access to care
and because we want to encourage new
vendors
new competition um
i'm proposing that we add 50 000
in general funds and the purpose of
those general funds is written in that
footnote
of the amount appropriated in this class
50 000 shall be used for the purpose of
providing incentive fees to first-time
contract awardees
not to exceed 100 000 or excuse me 10
000 per awardee
and also that those none of these funds
shall lapse within the biennium but will
lapse at the end of the biennium
so so this gives new
vendors a financial incentive
to bid on these family planning
contracts
so that we don't end up having
one entity exit the market without a
replacement
to to maintain a uh continuity of
operations
so that's what that 50 000 does
and it's basically says hey if you've
never received a family
planning contract and you're interested
in a bidding if you get the bid
we're going to give you a ten thousand
dollar bonus for uh participating
you could rationalize that a little bit
further that just to think that they may
have some startup costs that it could
help them with um so so
i would uh have us increase the general
fund
from
the governor's recommendation to 861
0805 an addition of 50 000
with the note that that that 861
is considerably more than it was in fy
when it was in the 596 category
so um with with that i'm i'm happy to
answer any of your questions of what
this hb1 is trying to do
and uh representative rogers
um yes i mean i i'm alarmed that you
want to drive people out of business
which you've tried to do with the first
gag order that you have in house bill 2.
not a gag order
there is no gag order please don't say
that there is no gag order
i'm going to say it because there is we
have a difference of opinion
so i can state my opinion right just
categorically you're wrong but go ahead
categorically i'm not but we have a
difference of opinion
we removed the gag order we removed the
gag order from the leon amendment
and it is not what we passed yesterday
there is no gag order
please do not mislead the public you can
live in your fantasy and you can mislead
the public but what you're trying to do
is all right i'm willing to take a
entertain a motion
to approve this uh part of the budget so
you're stopping discussions
i i i don't i'm not going to allow a
misrepresentation of
of uh facts and so i'm ready all right
you misrepresent the facts i'm ready to
vote
is there a motion
and you're not going to consider the
amendment that i'm on the so this has
been
moved and seconded is there any
conversation on this
uh hb1 proposal
not seeing any mr uh clerk would you
please take a roll
i have my hands chairman yes
representative weiler voted as
representative
bean yes representative walner
now representative
no representative rogers
no and i'm alarmed you won't let me
discuss anything
representative edwards yes
mr chair of the voters 4-3 all right
thank you um
so next up on the agenda
is um
let's look at the two back of the budget
votes on personnel and dollars please
sure
representative norgren do you have a
question or comment
question um sorry but could you
go over the schedule for the the day i
thought originally we were
gonna meet at 9 30 we were then gonna
recess
until two and i i just wanted a
clarification of
what your plan is for the day i i think
we're gonna have to um that that was an
initial concept but since we have a
quorum
and some of these are uh things that
we've talked about and looked at
and probably are ready to vote um
i'm i'm voting on them would you prefer
to have the back of the budget vote this
afternoon
representative norgren
um i i think whatever your plan is
obviously we need to finish today so
yeah
so i think i think we've had an
opportunity to to look at these
and um let's uh let's get into the
conversation part
representative rogers your hand is up
yes
are you going to um continue in the vein
if you disagree
anyone disagrees with you you're going
to cut off discussion
i i think it's fair to say that i've
never done that except
in this particular instance where um i
just think it's a factual
matter that you are misstating
what we voted on yesterday there was no
gag order we intentionally passed an
amendment that removed it
and i don't want to use this form
to misinform the public if you would
like to misinform the public
you're welcome to do that outside of
this hearing
so if you disagree with one of us you're
going to cut off the discussion
if you're misrepresenting obvious facts
yeah if you're misleading
the public intentionally yes and that's
my judgment if we have a disagreement on
facts in any item you will cut off this
discussion
i i would reserve the right to but
you'll you've worked with me for over a
month and you know that's not my style
my style is to encourage
the conversation and to support and
facilitate the exchange of opinions that
are
contrary to my own but i will not
allow an overt misrepresentation of
facts
be issued from uh one of these meetings
and if you want to misrepresent facts
you're welcome to do that
outside in my opinion i am not
misrepresenting the facts i'm clearly
stating them
and you are missing so i made a decision
that we're moving on
so you are going to cut me off whenever
i disagree with you thank you for
clarifying
i think my point is clear and it's not
exactly what you said but
if that's the effect you want to take
from it you're welcome to
it's very clear representative wallner
are we ready to talk about the back of
the budget yes ma'am
we're we're in the conversation mode
what would you like to say
anything well i'm looking at the um the
one that's up on the screen right now i
mean there are i guess there are going
to be
two back of the budget amendments and
i'm looking at the one that
um is a reduction of the workforce
for health and human services of 226
full-time positions and
they have just come through a pandemic
and they have worked so hard over there
to get new hampshire keep new hampshire
healthy and
to try to get us through what was a
terrible situation
for our state and for for the nation and
we've
um trying to get people vaccinated and
trying to
keep people from getting coronavirus
um and it's been a really hard year for
them and i know that
their vacancy rate has been high because
i'm sure that people had to stay home
with their families
and some people probably took early
retirement
concerned about their own health and i
think this is i think this
is a really important i think this is a
really
very devastating uh reduction of staff
over there
remembering that karen rounds came to us
and did suggest a hundred
positions i thought that was
i thought that was very brave of her to
do that and
um i really thought she was trying to
come to us with a good
with a good solution um to help
people move forward but now you've more
than
doubled her suggestion and
i just think this is going to be very
difficult for the department as they try
to rebuild
and that's what they need to do in the
next the next two years is rebuild that
um that department so i'm going to be
voting no
on this amendment and
hope that all of you will join me yes
ma'am i
i just want to clarify uh one thing i
and if ms rounds is on the line maybe
you want to bring her
in mr ripple okay and
and the thing i want to clarify is i
believe that
ms rounds it came to us with the hundred
at at my request and that she was
helping me um
in my request for 100 to figure out what
the financial impact was
so because i didn't know the average per
person
cost associated with that so i i don't i
don't want it left that she recommended
cut because i i i don't know that that
would be accurate
miss rounds do you have a comment on
that
good morning um i think that's correct i
mean i
would recommend that you fully fund all
of our positions because
going into our budget we have uh 88
positions that are currently unfunded
in the governor's proposed budget so um
but i don't think it's wrong to say that
if
if i was going to offer anything
the most i could ever suggest would be
and even that is going to be painful and
create problems in the department
because what i'm really looking at is
180 positions
from um from our authorized number
so to think that it's going to be
226 plus 88 it's almost 300 positions
that will be unfunded
in the house budget is very difficult to
think about
okay so thank you representative
did you i just wanted to make sure that
ms round's comments were on the record
accurately so
do you have any anything to say in
response to that
no i but i just thought that miss rounds
was um
very very generous when she came forward
with
that information about the hundred
positions and
um a very difficult thing for an
employee to do
and i appreciated her doing it and um
i think this when you realize that there
were already 88 positions and now
they're going to be
well over 300 positions um
i think this is really leaving the
department in a very a very difficult
place and representative oh i'm sorry
no that's all i have to say i just think
it's difficult
position to put them in
uh representative weiler do you have a
comment
question yes i think you missed
characterizing the set
act as if we're rebuilding a destroyed
agency this
agency had been given a task that was
monumental and growing
and it was something they were unable to
achieve
so this is basically removing many of
the vacancies and still leaving them
vacancies they can
fill so these this takes some heat off
them trying to fill and
create different departments that you
know we're in a
program that they're unable to fill
they're unable to find the places for
them
so this has taken there's no sense
in throwing money that cannot be spent
and if we don't even have these people
to put on the budget
then why would we put money in so what
we're doing is cleaning up to reality
in my mind thank you
representative nordron
well thank you mr chair i
i have trouble comprehending what
representative weiler just said but
um could you uh explain i i don't
remember the number of 3 000.
can you maybe give us a little
background on how that number was
arrived at
the 3 000 full-time
authorized positions okay i
uh i i can uh to a bit
so on the 11th of march
uh or as of the 11th of march i received
a vacancy report
from the department and
based on that vacancy report
they had 507 positions
vacant they were at
2 646 positions
filled in the governor's budget
i believe they were authorized three
thousand
two hundred and twenty six positions
the 226 cut
is to an extent just a little bit
arbitrary
but it takes them from the governor's
three two two six
to three thousand that three thousand
because of the vacancy rates as of the
1st of march
represents an additional hiring
opportunity for the department
of about 350 people
that 350 people
from a 2600 base
represents nearly a 14
increase in personnel above what they
had on hand
on the 14th of march or excuse me the
11th of march
and so given the repeated
remarks about there being a workforce
shortage
and um it
it it doesn't seem to me to be
um it doesn't seem to me to be a hard
management task
to grow their personnel by 14
above what they have today we're giving
them
more people to do the job now
it isn't as many people as they
requested
but to the request that we received
yesterday to make sure that we were
giving them
guidance i think our guidance in this
would be
we're still letting you grow
substantially 14 above what you have on
hand
350 positions but please
prioritize direct health care
because we try to protect those funds
and please
prioritize those requirements that you
have statutory
direction to implement and as we look
through the budget book and we looked at
the federal regulations and federal laws
and
state laws there's a whole bunch of
legal
requirements that the department has so
so this would kick it back
to their management team their
leadership team
to manage the growth because it's growth
and what they have to manage their 14
growth to emphasize
the direct support of our new hampshire
patients
and to um
enhance their ability to execute the
laws
that they're obligated to follow so
so that's that's that's the background
of the 226 number it was a it was a
number
that got us to 3 000 which is an easy
number to understand
so um yes ma'am follow follow-up
oh yes thank you um i guess i would take
issue or stress some concern
that um part of the the problem is the
fact that they
um have had trouble fighting
the last year and a half have been
an exceptional time in the country
and i think one of the issues that's
developed
is the whole issue of hiring and keeping
everything functioning properly so i i
think
for us to look back at this year
probably isn't a very reliable base to
look at
as far as their ability to hire so i
would just make that comment thank you
yes ma'am and just as another data point
um the the department was authorized
at the end of fy 19 2916 people
and so this budget would authorize 3 000
that's still an additional 84 people
above what they were authorized two
years ago
so so there is some rooms there is some
breathing room
for an effective management team to make
some priorities
and to create a plan i believe i trust
them
representative wallner your hand is up
do you have a question or is it
so the one thing i really dislike about
back of the budget
reductions and i have to say that you
know
they happen they've happened in many
many budgets
it means that you haven't really the
legislature
hasn't really come to grips with what it
is
we think we don't want the department to
do
and um i think that's unfair to the
department
and unfair really it really it
means that we are not doing what we were
sent here to do
if there are things that we think the
department doesn't need to be doing
then i think we should we should have
the
wherewithal to tell them that and if we
had gone through the budget
in a more methodical way
and looked at each department
in each division more carefully
and heard about what it means to reduce
staff
what it means to reduce spending in
certain areas
then i think we would have been able to
point to those areas that we think that
the department does not need to be doing
and so i think it this is just um
us not really meeting our our
responsibilities
thank you i i can understand that
perspective and from my perspective
we uh we went through every
uh au we looked at every line
in the financial statement um
every member of the committee had
an opportunity to ask questions and to
probe
and um and and that opportunity to ask
questions
was taken advantage of many times
about a week ago or so we
went through an ad back process
and everyone on the committee was
encouraged to participate
in advancing ad backs and
every member that brought forward a
recommendation or an idea
had an opportunity to explain it and to
make a case for the rest of the
committee to support it
so so while
in hindsight we may not have used the
three weeks
three and a half weeks as well as you
would like
i would nevertheless say that every
individual was
allowed an opportunity to make the most
out of the three weeks there was nothing
that we didn't give people an
opportunity to talk about
so um so that that would be my
perspective on that
and your hand is still up i don't know
if that's just because it's tougher
okay so uh
representative weiler
i would like to move uh amendment number
zero nine through six
your second second being moved and
seconded
is there for any further conversation
mr clerk would you take a role in favor
of amendment 0936
earth yes representative weiler votes
yes representative bean
yes representative wallner
no representative nordgren
no representative rogers now
representative edwards yes
mr chair the vote is 4-3
thank you um so then let's move to
the back of the budget cut the money can
you
bring that up yes
okay
all right so this was distributed
yesterday
um so people could think about it
overnight
oh why is there 30 million in the first
year and
and 20 million in the second year that
was
a distribution that i asked mr ripple to
put in
and what i thought would be big drivers
of those reductions
would be the management of the higher
lag
would be a big contributor in other
words
given that the department still has an
opportunity to uh add
14 more people than they had on staff on
the 11th of march
then the timing of those hires
could contribute personnel savings that
would show up in
these dollars so that that's that's a
key part of the theory
um are there are there any questions or
comments about this
representative
basically the same comments i had on on
the
um reduction of the uh
staffing i mean we went through the
budget
we've not given them any direction as to
whether where we think
they're doing things that we don't think
they should be doing
um and how they would cut basically 50
million
plus stand to lose
a large amount of federal money maybe as
much as another 50 million
um i don't think that's i don't think
that's wise budgeting at all
um and um i think that you know we're
just giving up the legislature's
authority
to make some of these decisions i mean
we leave everything to the executive
branch and um after a while
the legislature will just okay whatever
the executive branch
decides to do and i think that leaving
these decisions up to them without us
taking
our responsibility is a mistake
thank you again i can understand that
perspective
another perspective on this is that
the legislature isn't just accepting
what the executive branch gave us
from the governor's budget we're making
a significant change
uh it's still above what we did in fy 21
but it's less than what the governor
would project
would have had us do so we certainly
don't haven't given up our legislative
prerogative
there were a couple hb2 items in there
one we struck the 1.5 million
to do safety infrastructure and senior
citizen centers because we didn't think
it was a good idea
that it wasn't an effective program so
that was us saying
no let's not do that then um
we changed we made some other changes in
hb2 that are different than what the
governor wanted
for example we changed that lap state
for example
so so i don't i i don't think we've
given up
our prerogative and i i would say that
we have given
the department guidance
because you know half of this hb2 is
dedicated to saying
no reductions shall be made to
appropriations in the following area
developmental services including
acquired brain disorder services
and children's in-home support services
the children's health insurance program
or county programs including the state's
share of funding for nursing
facilities and other long-term care
services
so so those items represent
the general direction that we support
investments in direct health care
to put hands on the citizens and
patients in new hampshire that need
care and treatment and that
given that they operate in a heavily
legislated and regulated environment
between the federal government and the
state
government they are not suffering from a
lack of guidance
they have guidance more than they care
to
i'm sure so so i just
don't accept fully although i understand
where you're coming from i don't accept
fully the idea that we haven't provided
enough guidance
so are there are there any other
questions or comments
so i entertain a motion to adopt zero
nine four six
i'd move adopt amendment zero nine four
six
h to the h b
is there a second a second
moved and seconded um mr clerk are you
ready to take a roll
oh excuse me is there any discussion
you don't like discussion not not seeing
any discussion
ankle with your nails honey
you're not on mute uh representative
rogers i'm
just letting you know okay so mr clerk
would you take a roll
representative earth yes representative
weiler votes yes representative bean
yes representative walter
no representative
no representative rogers no
representative edwards yes
chairman the vote is 4-3
so that takes us down to two issues
um the sysc
and the dhhs
so mr ripple would you
would you just highlight or bring up the
dhhs
budget line request and then if you can
let's just um
go through the first 19 quickly so that
people know what those are
and then we can t up the issue on 20.
sorry we don't we don't need to do
anything i don't think other than
until this afternoon on it but but i
would like to tee up the information
exchange
you want to speak to this or do you want
ms rounds to speak to it however you
want to go
you know i think i would ask karen to
come in and speak to this
i think she's able to i am sorry
um so this is a pretty standard process
for us
uh lines 1 through 19 are
all change requests related to
financial reporting changes so they're
not programmatic changes
um they are changes in
we made a mistake in how we budgeted it
so that's what those changes are and
those net uh
about a 200 000
reduction in general funds um
and then number 20 uh you'll see that i
put some space between 19 and 20 so that
it's specifically
um called out is related to new
hampshire hospital
we um joe christie spoke
about this issue uh in his presentation
from new hampshire hospital
and we talked about in that presentation
that we would provide a change request
for the
issue so that's why it is reflected here
this is because there were enhancements
for mental health workers that were
voted on
just before the governor's budget was
finished they're voted on by governor
and council
and those enhancements were approved by
governor and council
the because of how late it was in the
governor's budget
they had already set the general fund
target and
there were not additional general funds
so to at least have a
total fund budget that was correct and
and reflect those expenditures
we added them as a hundred percent uh
other funds agency funds
but this request is to move them to
general funds which is where they
properly should be
also um is there a last page
with some of this detail uh in written
form
is that what where that was mr ripple so
each one of these has
its own page of backup information
um i'm just focused on number 20 because
i i
unless unless somebody wants to uh dig
into one of the other 19
i i just want us to know what we're
doing on 20 and then
people can ask otherwise
and so you'll see here that there's no
change to any of the expenditure lines
it's uh only a change to the revenue
lines
okay just you just said it i know you
did but
just say it one more time why
are we losing agency funds or is that
initially just a bookkeeping mistake to
begin with
uh so those agency funds really didn't
exist to begin with so it's not losing
anything as i mentioned during the
governor's phase
these enhancements for mental health
workers were approved by governor and
council
it was too late in the governor's
process to
uh add additional general funds uh there
were no other general funds to be had if
you will in the governor's phase
and so we added this as agency income
so that the expenditures were correct so
the total expenditures being 74.4
million
and 74.5 million are correct it's
that we were not able to add the general
funds so the correct revenue
the revenue source is incorrect
okay so in the letter that the governor
sent subsequent to his budget process
where he listed a few pages of
priorities that he'd like to have added
back
did since this was since this missed the
governor's budget phase
did his prioritizations include this
line
yes it did
then just for completeness sake mr
ripple if you have that
new hampshire hospital slide that we
we've already seen but it wouldn't hurt
to look at it again
i have the new hampshire hospital
presentation but i haven't found the
exact slide
um so i'll bring it up this could take a
minute though
all right ms rounds do you happen to
know which slide we should just go to
joan off the top of my head hold on
kevin it was it was towards the
middle to end of the new hampshire
hospital slides so
you know keep going
keep going wait last now
the last
accomplishment
somewhere in this area i thought
this yep right here 36.
okay so i faintly remember this slide
but enough to know that i've seen it and
but i understood it at the time
um so are there any
let's do it this way are there any
requests for information from the
committee
relative to lines 1 through 19
that was uh on the previous
view
amendment number
there's no amendment number since these
are changes to the appropriations in
house bill 1. i'm just pulling up the
trying to pull up the summary sheet
again here so you can all see that
and there is only there's one other
thing that i would point out just to
confuse things a little bit
and i mentioned this in an email last
night that the department submitted
these 20 items
one packet and then they also submitted
a last item
pertaining to let me see here
medicaid administration they submitted
this to separate separately when we put
together the packet i accidentally added
it on
to the end this is not included in the
original 20 items and karen i don't know
if you want to speak to this one
in other words are you saying this is
competing to be item 21
well there are yes you could consider
this item 21.
it is not on the summary sheet but it is
a department request
yes so this was something that was
pointed out during the medicaid
presentation when we were going line by
line that the
transfer to other state agencies which
is the dish payment to new hampshire
hospitals seemed kind of high compared
to previous years
and you guys were absolutely correct it
was too high it doesn't match what new
hampshire hospital is receiving for dish
so this is just making the adjustment
to the it's all federal to
actually represent what will be received
okay so so highlight the key line
for us if you would to see what we're
looking at
so because that's in parentheses
it's still a decrease though right the
6'5 is 6.5 million
yes it's a it's a decrease um to correct
what's actually being transferred to new
hampshire hospitals so that
34.2 million was actually was overstated
so that has no impact that that
that change has no impact on general
funds
it does not it's 100 federal
and although we would like that extra
6.5 million
we're not eligible and so this is just
getting our budget to
represent what we really think is going
to happen exactly
and to match what new hampshire hospital
actually budgeted
all right so are there does the
committee have questions
on 19 on item 20
and if we've called this item 21 or
this is the time to get your questions
answered
so that we can maybe uh vote this
afternoon
representative walner thank you
karen i know that um
the enhancements at new hampshire
hospital for the mental health
workers were there enhancements at
glencliff
also
there are some long-standing
enhancements that have been in place
at glencliff for a long time i don't
know
i don't know that glenn cliff has mental
health workers i think they're mostly
nurses and those have been budgeted
for several years thank you i just
wanted to be sure they
they weren't budgeted thank you yes
okay so um so with that
i i think um we're at the point where we
could take a recess
i i was saying that we needed to recess
until two
because it was uh my assumption that
we may have some documents coming in
from ols and we wanted to give them
maximum time
uh mr ripple have you gotten everything
from ols
that you've been expecting or wanting
yes we have everything
uh and i believe the committee has
everything the last items outstanding
were the sununu center
amendments that i sent out last night
yes sir
so okay so i i would
uh if if if we met again at one o'clock
instead of two o'clock
does that cause problems for
anyone yes okay what time do you need to
meet sir
well if i if i drive up for a
face-to-face meeting
at noon and if it goes an hour and then
i drive
home i'll be home at 2. so
so so let's go ahead and recess until 2
and at which time um we can
take votes on those 21 items that we
just looked at
that would buy you a few more minutes if
you're not able to join us sir
and then excuse me
and then i would think that um
at that point we'd be ready to go
through a walk through
the sununu center documents and that's
when i'd like to
turn the chair over to you and let you
walk us through that
okay all right and
and if you're not available are you okay
with representative wallner
uh maybe stepping in and walking us
through that
yes we're co-sponsors okay
representative walner would you be okay
with that
um yes okay
well so uh the committee stands in
recess
until uh 2pm thank you thank you
okay so it's two o'clock we're back from
our lunch recess
we have uh
is representative earth there oh there
you are up in the upper left
um so this afternoon
we left it to uh look at the dhhs
line items where they at we're asking
for
support then we have
a planned discussion around the
sununu youth center and a number of
amendments
each of which plays a part in
facilitating a close down we had
postponed a house bill 254
vote on monday because we needed to
get the ols amendment dealing with
um hb2 amendment uh incorporating the
254 language into it and we'll discuss
it today
as an hp2 and then i
i hope that we can uh then decide what
to do with hb
254. uh at that point
uh i'm going to um i'm inviting now
and i will invite again uh
representative rogers to
walk us through her hb1 proposal
related to the family planning lines
and um and i'll i'll check in with you
as we come towards the end of the sysc
uh representative rogers to to see see
where you're at on that
uh okay so mr
ripple if you could pull up the line
items
the hhs line items please sure
okay so there's at least two ways of of
uh
carving this up and i think
one way is um lines one through
20 on this sheet and then treat the
hypothetical 21 as a separate issue
or we could do 1 through 19 then 20
then the hypothetical so um
i'm going to get a sense of the
committee now on if the committee
is interested in considering 1 through
all in one piece or not if you do not
want to consider
1 through 20 all in one piece this is a
good time to
let me know
i'm not seeing anyone um okay
so um is there any conversation
on these 1 through 20.
right okay so i would uh i'd entertain a
motion
that the committee accept lines one
through twenty uh the
request by sources of funds for transfer
by the department
did you vote one through twenty or one
through nineteen
because the general fund increase i just
asked about one through twenty and
nobody had a problem with doing them all
at once
so it is one through twenty okay but i
think item 20 is the one that would
increase general funds by
4.3 million per year okay
so so you think we should go ahead and
do one through 19 separate that's fine
right we can do it that way so why would
entertain a motion to
uh for us to consider lines one through
nineteen as one unit of
transfers tumbler thank you is there a
second
okay seconded by two people
so um with it moved and seconded
is there any discussion
i think for the record this is all
routine normal
cleanups and has no real significant
impact on
our general funds um
okay so not seeing any further
uh conversation on that um
mr clerk would you take a roll okay
on the motion to accept uh
1 through 19 on the display before us
representative earth yes representative
weiler votes yes representative bean
yes representative walner
yes representative nordgren
yes senator rogers yes
representative edwards
representative edwards yes oh am i muted
no i'm not muted yes i didn't hear
anything yes
that's the chair that voted seven to
zero
okay thank you okay so with that
done um let's move on to
item number 20 the acute psychiatric
services
where the agency funds are decreased and
general funds are added to to the tune
of 4.2 million dollars
we discussed this over lunch prior to
lunch and we looked at the slide that
the new hampshire hospital presented to
us over
a week ago um is there any
uh discussion on that mr ripple just for
completeness do you do you have
that slide from the new hampshire
hospital on this
it was like slide 34 or something like
it was i think i
closed it out um i can find it again
here hold on
okay i just thought seeing it might
stimulate some conversation
sorry i didn't give you a heads up
that's okay
mental health worker enhancement it's
like slide 36 i was off a couple
um so this is to remind you what this is
about
the agency funds that were in the budget
aren't real and so they need
geneticizable
fungus is there any other discussion
representative irf representative weiler
where does the money come from this
would be
a gen uh a replacement of
agency funds that aren't really there
and it would have to be backfilled with
general funds so this is in addition to
what we've done
it it would show up as an addition
wouldn't it mr ripple
yes it would
nine million dollars
yes approximately
in the over the biennium
i guess we got it well and also this is
this looks to be an explicit direct
effort to address the emergency room
boarding
situation which i think i think we've
all discussed as being
a critical thing for us to do but it is
a lot of money
but we just got worried we got more
uh is there any other conversation on
this
okay so um not hearing any
and generally perceiving a reluctant
consensus to accept
um i would uh let's let's hear a motion
on
accepting line 20 of the agency budgets
adjustment
i would move to accept line number 20
with the acute psychiatric services
transfer of funds from an agency account
to the general funds accounts
account is there a second second
it's so moved and seconded is there a
discussion
not seeing any uh mr clerk would you
take a roll
on the motion there the 4.2 and 4.8
million
uh representative earth yes
representative wylo votes yes
representative bean
yes representative walner
yes representative
yes representative rogers yes
chairman edwards yes
the vote is seven to zero okay thank you
um mr ripple could you go to the last
page then
so remind me what this is
this is a decrease of 6.52 million
of transfers that to other state
agencies that won't take
place so this this looks like a
reduction in our general funds
obligations
it's not a general fund reduction it's a
federal fund reduction
but it would be for the reason that you
mentioned yes
okay so is there a conversation on this
and we we this is out our control
anyways right i mean this is just
we're not getting this federal money so
all we're doing is we're getting our
books in alignment with the projected
reality
i believe so yes is the four seven zero
zero one zero uh a way to identify this
is that the au um
it is
what you said it's au 79 37.
79 37.
so the motion on this would be to update
hb1 to reflect 6.512 million
less in federal funds availability
i would make that motion it also
includes the same amount of nearly that
same on the second year as well
yes is there a second
second it so moved and seconded
mr clerk would you call a roll
okay on the reduction of six and a half
million less federal funds
for each year
representative earth yes representative
weiler votes yes
representative bean yes
representative walnut yes representative
yes representative rogers yes
chairman edwards yes
it's the chair of the voters send them
to zero okay
well thank you so that's uh completed
uh i think we can go into the
sununu youth center conversation of the
amendments that we have to hp2
i would like to just share a couple of
thoughts
that i that i worked out with mr ripple
and um
and a little bit with representative
walner uh
with mr ripple uh we discussed
you know how is it possible for us to go
through these today and still finish
today
and given that we can anticipate there
are probably some areas that we need to
fix
like for example representative walner
noticed that
we had a consumer protection advocate
and not a child protective
advocate in the text so that's like a
typo that needs to be fixed but there
are other things
for sure that as we go through these
that we'll want to fix
so as i understand it if we can
get agreement on what
kind of um modification or correction
that we want to make to these hb2 items
we can vote on it contingent upon
the changes being made by ols
and then if the changes come through ols
as we've voted for it then they're
agreed upon and
and they've had our vote if
we send these to ols get them back and
they're not
what we want then we still have in the
house calendar
a work session for friday that we could
use
to as you know the one last thing to do
i really don't want to do that i hope we
can succeed in getting
this done today um and uh
so so then the other thing i would point
out is that there's a few things here
uh that have been proposed that may be
rather than
uh hardwiring with the hb2 that we leave
it to the discretion of the commission
to
to handle so that would mean that we
probably want to agree
on what the commission looks like
earlier in this conversation than later
but that's just a thought um and
at this point uh representative weiler
if
if you're prepared sir i'll i'll turn
over the
chair position to you well i'll give it
a try and hope uh
representative helps me out the
first one that seems to try to combine
them all is number zero nine
five four h it's about seven pages it's
the most
lengthy one and what i'll try to do is
break it down
what the components are that went into
it and i'll ask
wong and help me out so it looked to me
like
zero nine five zero might be the
the beginning of this and i believe uh
mary jane correct me if i'm wrong this
is kind of bringing in 254
right okay so so zero nine
five zero uh starts off the way 254
did and that's the first roughly
uh pages of
zero nine five
four so representative weiler
could i just make makeup i i
so um well
you're doing fine and just when i had
looked at it i thought it actually might
be
easier to go through the individual
pieces
that we had okay than to use the
it's it's strictly your true i mean it's
your choice i just
thought maybe the pieces were easier for
people to pull up the pieces
and look at them rather than to try to
go through it it is quite lengthy when
you put it all together
should we begin with 0926
that's where i started okay so 0926
is kind of a summation of
house bill 254
and what it does is it talks about not
putting so many children
in such um strict confinement
and finding a way to find them
uh situation so that maybe there's
something comes of their confinement and
of their correction
and with the exceptions of murderers
and that seems like along the lines of
what i think we all have been working
toward
um do we want to do these one at a time
and do a roll call or do we just want to
kind of do them all together and then
make a decision at the end
what's the choice
mr chair you're muted do you have any
i did i just went into the back bench
role pretty naturally
i i think um it's really how
representative wallner and you care to
proceed i
it it feels to me like we might
be able to make more progress if we just
looked at the components and
if if if they feel right to voting on
them
let's vote on them if they don't feel
right because there's some other pieces
that we want to look at
i i think maybe we should just try to
get our arms around the ones that
kind of fit together but i don't i don't
have that
that puzzle in my head of how these
things fit together
okay and then representative nordgren
has her hand up sir
representing thank you
both of you your chairs so when we
met at lunch mary jane and kathy and i
we put them in the order we thought
we should talk about how it fit together
so help me out with the order heard me
i haven't had a chance to okay
so do you want me to go through the
order we had and if you don't like it
that's fine
so the first one we had was as you said
mr chair was 9 26 that's number one
okay number number two we had was a
closure
which is nine three seven
all right give me a moment to find that
i've got it that'd be number two the
third one we thought was 950
and that's the creation of the
commission
and i think we also saw one change there
and um so so that number is 950 that's
number three
okay and number four
uh is something i think
uh we thought
and that number is 9 30.
we thought this was something and i
think
representative uh osborne
no wrong edwards mentioned
that uh some of them needed to just go
to the commission
for them to deal with rather than us
trying to micromanage
so this one 930 would be
one that we thought should be out but
should be
part of the commission charge
and this is number four 9 30.
and then number five
would be 9 34
and this is also
something we thought the commission
should deal with
this is a contract for another state for
the provision of secure
juvenile correctional services we
thought we did not want to preempt what
the commission
might decide and put this in an rsa
um talk about out of state right
right we also wanted to talk about the
650 000 that's in that but we can do
that when we get to number five
numbers number six uh
would be 932
and uh we
we can get to that and discuss what we
thought our changes should be
but that would be number six 932
number seven would be
um the
job creation bill 942
and that would be something that we
should
talk about
and then the last one is number eight
and that's 9 33
and this is something we can talk about
when we get to it
um um i think the date of 222
is good because there there could be an
interim
discussion with the commission about
what to do
with that entire state property so
i that's something we should talk about
when we
talk about number eight which is 932
so that me trying to be organized
and i get a little obsessive about that
i'm sorry
you got to get organized somehow all
right number one let's start with that
any uh any discussions any wishes to
change that
all right what i'm hoping is that we can
put aside and maybe in one vote
uh make a motion for like one two three
seven eight or whatever like however we
decide
but this is basically 254 we've had time
to look at this
it's the way that the uh the last bill
that's kind of
everything cobbled together starts
any objection to putting that in a
collection
so i i do have a question on
the effective dates um uh
[Music]
sorry um hey um
ms o'neill uh sent us a really nice
document
uh summarizing some some questions i had
put to her
and in her response
one of the things that i i thought may
be helpful is she laid out a
projected um
project timeline and
i just am curious if these effective
dates
conflict with that or if we want to try
to
maybe it's not worth trying to wrestle
ms o'neill's projected project timelines
with these effective dates
i i would draw my my comment i just
talked myself out of it
i i thought it might be useful to make
sure that we weren't
breaking anything by taking her project
timelines it may make a lot of sense
and then immediately having the wrong
effective dates here
well if if the if we empower the
commission to do a lot of this
time setting and goal setting contract
and so on
that may take care of itself yes sir the
difference here is this is the
incarceration standards though yes
this is a pretty big one where the
effective dates i think really need to
be important
so do you think they need to be earlier
than march 22.
i i i ask the question i don't i defer
to the experienced folks on the on the
committee
if that's if those look like the right
effective dates on
changing incarceration standards
well this is toward the end of the time
we're giving them say from july 1st to
the following march so
at about that time they should be taken
seriously
a change of incarceration and start to
begin the process of getting all the
people out of there so
good just for representing better ideas
[Music]
i think i i think the march date
i think the march date works will work
um you know but as i thought about this
whole
um group of amendments and
this whole issue is there are a lot of
people who have a lot of
different opinions about about this and
i think
what we're doing is that we're sort of
we're helping us take the first
step obviously the senate is going to
weigh in
um there are a lot of people who have a
lot of
differing opinions and um that are going
to
have their chance to weigh in on it so i
think what we need to do is put it out
there if it seems like
the march date is wrong i think we can
work with the senate around that
um the senate will have their own
thoughts and then we'll come together as
a committee of conference and probably
um come up with a final
a final proposal so i sort of see it as
a this is
sort of like the first step we're sort
of on first base here
thank you representative rogers
yeah the um commitment date was passed
by child and family law
which is a policy committee and i think
that they did a lot of work on that so
i believe that we should um trust the
policy committee on what they did on
this
and not second guess them okay
thank you very much if there's nothing
further on
on this zero nine two six h we'll put it
in a queue
to perhaps be voted on in one vote
we move on to zero nine three
seven this is the closure in the
transfers
for incarceration july 1st 2022 that's
what we talked about
what we wanted then the
fiscal committee the general courts will
have authority to accept funds from any
source to approve the transfer of funds
and so on and so forth
notwithstanding other provisions neither
the department of health human services
or any other administration agency or
authority
remember the executive branch of
government shall expend or commit the
expenditures of any funds from any
source to directly or indirectly fund
this
centers for a successor state facility
kind of make that clear of that closing
date
anybody have anything to add on that
if not i'll place it in the queue for
collective vote
okay then the next one
i think i've got yeah i've got him in
the right order zero nine
five zero h very critical this is the
commission
and we talked about having a correction
here
the director of the office of consumer
advocate
you're going to change that to what
child advocate
yes i think i think the consumer
advocate would be really surprised to
hear that um
yeah so i think we met child advocate
there all right
make that uh revision subject to change
this one
three zero and i subject to change
something to highlight there it is
i will say on this one uh chairman
weiler
there are a lot of different opinions
i've received
two or three um emails this morning
about differing um commission members i
haven't really had
a chance to really think all of that
through
um what we have here before us is a
is a proposal but i think it's another
one of those things i think that
over the next several weeks
we can probably work on trying to flush
out
who the appropriate who might be
appropriate i
i just have i have not had the time to
go through all the different suggestions
so
um yeah and we see that they have short
time to work we want to report by
september
30th of this year they may not be
appointed until july
so we don't have much time
uh chairman uh edwards
so i i have just two comments on this uh
one of them is
similar we we call out waypoint by name
and we call out the disability rights
center by name
and uh and i i i'm not sure exactly what
the disability rights center is but
but when we call out waypoint i think
waypoint
is one of several organizations that are
in this
space and i would uh although they
they may end up having somebody
designated from waypoint
i don't think calling out one
organization
by name unless it's a state agency
is is is just good policy when we're
setting up a commission
so i i i would like to find a more
generic way
to reference that representative of
waypoint
and maybe of the disability rights
center i have
less of an opinion on that
my second point is that i
think we really need to have
sort of the neighborhood family support
group
whoever community this might go into
these may go into i think we need to
have
i i don't know for the lack of a better
word you know the the
the mom's view of her raising her family
where these kids may be transferred to
i'd like a public safety advocate to be
on the commission
because if we get a bunch of people who
all sort of think the same that we have
to take care of these kids
and we don't have the other point of
view that well we got to also take care
of the safety of the community
i just think we may miss a vital
representation
so but that's my thought and and
but to representative walner's point
i i'm okay with us
um somehow communicating to the
senate that this commission membership
would need some work
okay you can't offhand think of a group
that would serve the purpose of the
public safety advocate
i i can't i i think you know the you
know the members of the
committee may know people or know a way
to say that i i just don't
this is not my subject matter
but you know you uh are opposed to
pointing out by name
waypoint and disability rights well more
waypoint
i because i'm not really sure what the
disability rights center is
if that's a government entity uh part of
the state
and it's i think it's fine if they're
not then i think it's worth a discussion
to
make sure that we're not picking you
know
picking our jury i don't know here's
here's my thought
people that came forward and were
willing to help were mike skibby
disability rights center and of course
john dejoy
from waypoint willing to take an active
role and
so that's the kind of person that if you
put it on this commission
would stay active and have a good
background obviously they had enough
background to come forward
to talk to us so i think that's why
you know their names ended up in here
because they had already
wanted to be involved and you know if we
put somebody on
that is this a short time
i've had things like this before where
we put together a commission
and we waited for some group to appoint
someone to the commission
and we waited and waited and now we only
have a short couple of months here to
come up with a decision and if we're
waiting a month and a half for somebody
to appoint something from a group
um the rest of them are sitting around
wondering when they're going to
call a meeting so it makes sense yes or
no
i'm fully prepared to determine your
judgment i
i but that doesn't keep me from having a
stray opinion sorry
all right but um you know i think that
if we wanted to hit the ground running i
can depend on two people john dejoy and
mike skibby to
jump right in uh and let's have you know
less
problem and sometimes it's the senate
that holds us up with
appointing people because i don't see
any of them want to be interested
and uh you know the even the direct
the office of child advocate well that's
that's the state employee so they ought
to be able to come right over there
director of division for children needs
and families yup
so if we want people
hit the ground running and as soon as
this passes
then i think if we left those two people
and it will happen
uh we'll try to talk to the senate in
the meantime about
i agree with you there's going to be a
lot of objection
15 year old boys next to my 12 year old
daughter or something you know did you
see that
big objection but
maybe the senate will have somebody who
will something will occur to us in the
meantime so that's
number three that may go in the queue
without objection
representative rogers something
yeah um as far as a public safety
advocate or somebody there
to speak to that um if this site is
are there sites that are going into the
community they will obviously deal with
the local people
and um there will be hearings as far as
various locations in the community
and at that point the local police will
be involved as far as
where they're cited and priestful there
so i think that each of the localities
will have their public safety
advocates involved at that time so i
think that that's something that the
commission will be dealing with
and probably also the local planning
board correct
you know okay so without objection i'll
put that in the collective queue for now
number three
move on to number four which is zero
nine three zero
this is the contract is currently
providing residential treatment for
children
contractors should comply and so on and
the dcyf shall negotiate contracts for
residential placement with minors in new
hampshire
they're eligible for commitment and so
it empowers them
dcyf to begin working on
excuse me getting additional
uh places outside of
sununu youth center which is kind of
compulsory after you accept 254 on the
first part of this
the uh any comments on that part
represent
um i would like to see i i i think this
part
could come out and um leave this to the
commission
and i think this is yeah this is the
kind of thing the commission
and certainly dcyf has the authority
already i believe probably to negotiate
contracts so
um i would i would personally leave this
this piece out anyone object to leaving
this out
your hand or speak up if without
objection we will take this out
nice guys your question about that ever
would i'm fine with it coming out i'm
just wondering though would dcoaf
would at least somebody from this or
some part of the state be responsible
for doing that this
what this refers to dcy of doing as
opposed to somebody outside of the state
like the commission
i mean if we don't have something in
directing them to do something you don't
think they will
i'm just asking if you remove this piece
yeah are we still
sure that the state will be negotiating
contracts whether
as opposed to the commission negotiating
contracts
um all right left in
i know i'm just asking the question i i
don't know the answer
okay representative nordgren do you have
the answer well
i'm not sure but but i would think that
it would be the purview of the
commission
to make recommendations to the
department i don't
believe the commission would negotiate
with contractors
so i don't think this exact wording
would be
what's put in the commission's charge
but i do think
that it would be better not to have it
in this package the way it is
okay so unless uh unless representative
earth wants me to leave it in i'll take
it out
no i'll go with the judgment of the
people that have been here longer than i
have
representative edwards
yes sir this is just a process issue but
as we go through and we
drop these things that we're considering
and saying the commission can do it
i just hope we're keeping track of so
that in the commission's
section we're adding responsibilities so
that they know they have to do it
okay we'll make sure we have that
language in there we'll review that once
more before we do the final
okay number five i guess i had a note on
this
um again securing secure juvenile
corrective service contract
and uh again it comes down to the
department
and compliance the prison this is prison
or rape elimination
and i think this this one this one
talks about um sending some of the
children out of state
and i think that um it's
it's certainly not a good idea to send
children out of state it's really
kind of a bad it's bad for children and
bad for their families
but also i think that we have to let the
commission try to
try to come to um some decisions
about what kinds of facilities there
are going to be available in new
hampshire so um
i would i would leave this piece out
this doesn't seem like it really belongs
in this sorry my dog doesn't like it
either
okay representative my concern if you
take it out is
we're setting a date certain for closing
the facility
and if by that time they've not found a
place to put those
people that cannot be placed in the
community
and the only alternative is out of state
isn't this essentially saying
that option is available to you
i guess uh speak for representative
waldman
we don't want to make people think
that's that's the way we start out
immediately but
within six or eight months maybe
somebody will have some alternative that
they will
find it an abandoned jail or a van and
something that
that uh would work they could make
clear enough to fulfill this
this requirement okay so
we we will hopefully have time next
session if these things don't happen
start putting more legislation in
could i just speak for one a minute a
little bit about
down at the bottom though we did have an
appropriation here of 650 000
and i think i think no matter
what we're going to need those pieces of
funding that piece of funding um to help
with um finding
appropriate places for these for these
children
and you'll see the next piece that we're
going to do
in um this series of amendments
is the contingency fund so i i would
i would move when we get to the
contingency fund that we move the 650
to the contingency so the department has
the funding it's going to need for for
places for these children
whether it's no matter what they how
they decide to deal with
um those children i didn't think we had
money in this
number five like it's right down at the
bottom
um
see it online all right so we can add
that to the next one
i think it's needed all right with that
with that in mind
anybody uh object to
leaving this for the commission moving
the 650 into the next one
so that one's out with the money moving
into this number six which is zero nine
three
two so we add
650 000.
i guess when we get through we'll have
to wait for re-drafting
ols unless we want to accept
what we've done without the thought in
mind but i don't suppose that's correct
we would do it
so number six
is
kevin i did rewrite some words didn't i
um to add to 650 to bring the 650
forward um to the contingency plan
yes let me find that
so i added to the 14
to the 1.4 million i added the 650
to bring it up to two 2 million
50 000 um and it can be
used for related activity these
contingency funds may be
used to contract for contract amendments
uh employee retraining and relocation
costs
and other expenses as necessary
i think the department would would know
which
which expenses they're going to need
funding to
to to do and then the um
the funding should not lapse um until
june 30 of 23.
okay
so that would take care of six anything
else and number
six anybody else representing earth well
just going back to
934 that particular
paragraph by the money make specific
reference to rsa 169-b
colon 15-c is that
and basically expended to accomplish the
purposes of that
rsa now i've not looked at that rsa but
might be relevant that that be included
in
what representative wallner just
suggested good suggestion
okay rsa 169
percent okay i'm sorry
15 sweet okay
you get that uh mr ripple i'm bringing
it
i do have that reference yes i'm just
bringing up
that part of the law representative
mentioned
so that statutory reference for the
entire
plus million that would be in the other
amendment
this is just for the 650 the other
amendment relocation
and training and other stuff that
doesn't have a reference to an rsa
okay
should be a separate sentence like that
okay um so i'm trying to look that up
good and i can find 15
and 15 a
and 15 b
but i don't see a 15 c
i guess this would create it what is
what is the rest of 169 about
um no detention at jail is 169-b
colon 15. following arraignment
no minor shall be attained in any
facility where adults charge
actually this i think is important
because
one of the points that i've heard
expressed is that these
folks must not be put into or not be
jailed with adults that's what this is
related to
is b is a excuse me and b
is notification of write to request
records
and i don't see a c unless these
documents that we're going through now
are going to
specify a c this would create one i
guess
i'll just draw your attention to that
yes there is
one of the sections i'm not sure which
one but i'm looking at the omnibus
amendment now
it does create 169b15c
so there's probably more to this
language than just this one
as long as it's included in the where
representative walnut said we should
move the money to
and kept with that money i think is
probably the important piece right
i think so
all right so the omnibus one
had that same thing created what is
representative weiler yes that um that
is in the out-of-state placement part
it's just needed for the out-of-state
placement
so that rsa would have been created it's
not really needed
yeah so that's only for out of state
right
so that's not needed it would be if we
had the out of state placement it would
be needed but with this it's not
it's creating a new um rsa
so if we can't find any other place for
these
we don't need that rsa you still don't
need that rsa
we don't it would be a new one that
would be created under the um
the out-of-state placement section we're
not putting in
six fifty thousand there's a legal
opinion so without objection we'll leave
out that
okay i just want no money someone called
me and told me that it worked on writing
it
very good all right
so um take the 650 000
without the rsa language and place it
in number six
which is 0932h well i don't think you
need the money there because the money
was for the out-of-state placement
but but they will still need to well
even if there's an in-state placement
they need the money
right they'll still need the money for
they'll still need the money for placing
those children
for finding placement for those children
um
i think that the objection really has
been to
designating out of state is like the
first thing we do
um the department and
will still need to find placements for
those children
what i mean there may there the
commission will probably have
a lot of experts come in we have set
aside a hundred thousand dollars for
them to hire
an expert to come in and a consultant to
come in and
help them um with some of those
decisions so
i think they'll still need and this is
not we have not given them very much
money to do this
okay but nonetheless then are you then
tying them the 650 000
at least to the placement as opposed to
just a generic amount of money
added into the next section
uh contract amendments which could be
amendments with
um would be amendments with existing
providers
um and i think i think
other expenses as necessary
and that's the way i wrote it that might
not be the
legal that would certainly
give the department the flexibility to
do what they needed to do
well i'm just trying to understand what
you're saying i think this number
34 as you've explained it to me is
related to the placement of the children
or the young adults that can't be placed
in the community
and all i'm asking is should the and so
if that's true
then this money seems to be associated
with
that desire whether it's in state or out
of state
and if we're then going to move this
money to a different
place shouldn't go along with the notion
of placement that's what i'm trying to
understand
representative waller is that the way
you wrote the language
well i just i i moved the money i i just
moved the 650
000 into the contingency plan
um into the contingency amendment
so that the department could would have
that money available
um i guess my concern is they come back
and save money to put them into
other placements as opposed to but
should we add that in the list of things
yeah that should be added as an
amendment because otherwise
it could all get used up in placement
and training and
oh gee we didn't know we need to put
money aside for that
you know so yeah i think i think we'd
feel more comfortable
if this was dedicated to the placement
of the
encouragement so representative irfa or
maybe kevin can could we add
that in the list would that be the right
place
or should we take the 650 and have a
separate sentence
and say for placement
let's see
i think you could add it to the language
here
that's on screen here
so add it to the list and what would we
what would we say
what do we say 650 000
shall be given to this organization and
the dcyf
to provide for secure
confinement for the the few
uh ones who are not entitled to be moved
to a lesser confinement
and i'm okay with that kind of language
just being another clause of the
sentence that you guys you're trying to
do representative walmart
relocation costs and
uh placement of those that cannot be
placed in the community
yeah that's a good line
yep and 650 000
for the placement of those who cannot be
placed in the community
any community setting
okay so in that case i would say that of
the 2.05 million
650 000
shall be used for the purposes of secure
those who cannot be placed in community
settings
is that correct let's see where the 2.0
is
okay it's included in the 1.4 all right
yes that's good okay
okay so number six
is going to have that language added
also employee return retraining
retention relocation
cost uh described in action
something an alternative prison capacity
where is that described section
something do we need to write something
in there
or is that somewhere else
in these pages
because number seven has similar
language
zero nine four two h we've got a half a
million in there
maybe we should maybe we should take
maybe we should take out
um employee reta training and relocation
costs
i mean it's just in the list of things
that are allowed but in
devon we really specify that it's to be
used for that
[Music]
so we have we have a lot of things in
number six with 3932
contract amendments employee retraining
relocation
so number seven is kind of repetitive
unless we had to add that money back in
well did you want me to remove the
retraining and relocation costs from
the new number six or did you want to
change number seven instead
i'm wondering if seven is is duplicative
of six
okay let me bring up number seven here
i think seven does more than just um
[Music]
then just provide the funding for the uh
training and
i think it also talks about um
it talks about filling positions in
existing state agencies with
priority given to state employees
displays
i mean i think this is really important
we have a valuable workforce
at the sununu center um who certainly
have a lot of skills
and i think we want to be sure that they
get first
you know get the first ability to go in
jobs that are available within the
department or within
other agencies of the state
could be complying from fine five six
and seven
what why don't we do this why don't why
don't we take out
of six since it seems like it is
repetitive
why don't we take out of the list in six
why don't we take out employee
retraining
and relocation costs just take it out of
there
and address that in seven
okay
take it out of six and leave it in seven
does that make sense
i'm putting the 650 000 in two six
yeah put the 650 000 into six
and then do the the employees will be a
separate amendment
makes more sense
okay so i think i've got it so
just so unclear the language we're
looking at now the new number six
employee retraining and relocation costs
would be removed
do you want to include
so is literally all that's left for
contract amendments
as as well as the 650 thousand dollar
carve out for
placements for those who can't be placed
in the community
we want those included okay so does the
2.05 million still remain in the new
number six
yes it does okay okay
so i have a question okay
when we say retraining and relocation
i'm curious about the word relocation
in in the corporate world that means
that we would pay
all the moving expenses related to
moving from one part of the state to the
next
and and that can be eighty ninety 90 000
per household are we are we meaning
to move somebody from manchester
up to coast county if that's the
relocation
i i did i i did not write that words
those words so i don't know what
if representative weiler has an opinion
on that i think there might be
maybe probably better better words
it might be possible that we if our
workforce at glencliff
is really in
as bad as i mean if they they need if
they need people up there that might
might be something you might really want
to think about
well if we make it partial relocation
costs
then it's a little more negotiable
so so you want to you want to help them
pay for some of their
expenses of selling their house moving
their household goods
arriving at the new location with
closing fees
i mean that's the kind of thing that
goes into a reload
yeah i recommend deleting the word
relocation myself
because that i i think it's ill-defined
and it could be
tremendously expensive yeah i had a
neighbor that had
relocation costs he moved a wood pile
and i thought i can't believe it but
somebody else was paying for it
so so and unless we have a good
definition for that i
i would ask
all right any objection to deleting
relocation
could we leave in something like
training
job training and incentives to fill jobs
which exists within state government
yeah we could change it to incentives
and that
that's a little more negotiable
at one point i remember years ago and i
can't remember in one of these
in one one one previous try
um we talked about um severance pay
packages
and um i mean that that was all
that's that's not included here but i
mean we have had a lot
of discussion with the kind of things
that would cost
that we should be providing for
employees when we're closing this
facility
well retraining is a big
returning's good yeah see if it's six
months to do it
and we're paying them while they're
retraining
and you know that could that could be
expensive to give them the regular pay
for six months while
going to school may even be more than
moving costs
and then maybe incentives
wouldn't hurt so much but if it's
ill-defined are they going to sue us
you know the union's always ready to do
[Music]
that
anybody objectively taking out
relocation
that's going to be a sticking point
all right without objection let's take
out relocation
okay yeah i couldn't believe it when
this guy moved the wood pile
and he had a bunch of furniture that he
almost got rid of after he moved because
the house he moved in it wasn't as big
as when he moved out
minus the six whatever
refers to sections are we gonna write
those sections or yeah
we're gonna we're gonna rewrite them a
little bit six and seven
okay because it talks about contract
amendments describing section and
alternative prison prison capacity
described in section
yes okay so my understanding was that
this new
wording that i'm sharing on the screen
was going to replace 932
is that not the case in its entirety
sure oh okay that makes it easy
yeah 9 30. yes 932
will be replaced in its entirety by the
language i'm sharing right now
right minus relocation costs minus
minus one location minus relocation
costs
minus employee retraining still no no we
leave that in
okay so only minus relocation costs
with the carve out for six hundred fifty
thousand dollars previously discussed
okay
president organ has her hand up by mr
chairman okay
representative
thank you mr chair um
did we want to add the word incentives
in there or is that just
adding a complication that's in
the amendment 942 yeah well he's left in
other expenses
as necessary to cover that probably
covers it thank you
i hope depending on who the people are
making the deal
so that so we changed six
and seven and we took the language there
i think you need the same change in
seven to take relocation out
yeah okay and that's where
you can leave the word incentive there
is it there yes
line four okay
yeah okay good that should be good
any anything else are we uh accepting
seven and six as rewritten
six is rewritten and seven the objection
to seven
well with this amendment if seven is
942.
uh did you already remove the word
relocation in line one
and and are we correcting the typo in
the year
of line three not yet
okay oh yeah
all right every training relocation yeah
we should take relocation
out of line one you could say unrelated
incentives
yeah yeah related change into related
okay so the changes to this one the
removal of relocation in two places and
fixing the typo in the fiscal year on
line three
yeah and then i'm just curious if this
is
if the if the intent of this is actually
necessary because
the prioritization of an employee being
moved to another position within the
state
if their positions being phased out i
would assume is already in law somewhere
because that's just the rational human
resource thing to do
and so i'm just i kind of wonder if this
is necessary
beyond the money component of it
again it's not my area though i don't i
don't know i don't have any experience
with that either
maybe it's just belt and suspenders
maybe it's just you know make sure that
um it's understood that these employees
will
be able to be prioritized
well personally i'm i'm fine with saying
it twice but
some people aren't if this is already an
rsa somewhere i just
and if it's redundant so it's not
embarrassing
i don't i don't have an objection so
fiscal year ending june 30th 20
oh i see this yeah it doesn't have zeros
okay
yeah that was the date we wanted
2022.
okay we all set with seven
so number eight
is uh 0933
disposal property
this is where they take possession
and they can consult with manchester for
the sale
doesn't it doesn't forbid them from
repurposing into something else
well it does say consistent with the
expressed city interest does that mean
the city could say we want it
as long as they want to pay enough we
want to pay a decent price
yeah so so
earlier when we talked about an intense
statement
i i quoted the idea of saying that
the legislative intent was to have this
property
repurposed to tax production
certain uses and i
i would hate to see this beautiful
campus
that could be a wonderful software
development center
like they have out in silicon valley of
california i'd hate to see that turned
into
manchester's new city hall i i think
that's
valuable a property to not
get a highly productive use out of it
i'm i'm uncomfortable with this disposal
approach
um
well it says for the best interest of
the states
so
expressive city interests and the
interests of the state
did you say the best interest of the
state which would mean the highest price
a suggestion for the wording
representative oh
thank you mr chair yeah i i think um
when we've been talking um all afternoon
about the commission
and not and not giving them direction
on how to do things but letting them
go through their process i worry also
worried about
the disposal word in this section
because that might not be to the benefit
of the state and i
worry that we shouldn't have that in an
rsa
what word would you use i guess i
wouldn't
i guess i wouldn't i would have them
take possession
but i would not have them disposed
well it's kind of a neutral word like
we had a disposition motion on this bill
in other words have we disposed of it
but we find a way to finish
with it so well it depends what you mean
by the word disposed does it mean we
give it
to another department in the state or we
need to
just sell it tune outside interest i
guess i just
worry about binding the state
and the commission into doing something
that might need more discussion
would you prefer a word like transfer
do we have to say anything can we just
delete the language and
not decide that today right i think we
should just take
i think we should just end this
paragraph where it said
south river road manchester new
hampshire
and leave the rest of it out you leave
it up to administrative services
yeah the administrative services shall
take possession
and then not direct them what to do
yeah they'll be able to figure it out
although luke alessandra will probably
add back in every
time i know i i think lou's gonna
probably be messing with this quite a
bit
all right any uh any support for that
taking out all this stuff after uh
standing
i like her suggestion
okay if nobody puts a hand up on
representative
wallner no i'm i'm i'm fine with what
sharon said
what representative norbert said okay
um but you still have your hand up
representative
oh i'm sorry all right so if nobody
objects that's
where this thing will end um right
now notwithstanding
all right so we've been through the
sections
that kind of mirror what's in the
omnibus bill
leaving out some other parts that uh
are more objectionable by some of the
folks and
mr ripple what do you recommend should
we make a motion on the parts that we
have
approved or just leave it in your hands
to write in another omnibus
uh amendment um
so here's what i'm thinking i'll briefly
summarize
my understanding of what you want out of
these
okay i think it would probably be best
if i
bring these to os they redraft
whether in the form of individual
amendments or an optimist amendment i'm
not sure
but then i'll send that back out to you
and i think
i had originally suggested friday but
perhaps tomorrow or
the the chair can weigh in on what what
date is best
the division should come back and then
vote on
the revised amendments i think that's
the approach
i had originally suggested friday but i
didn't realize
that it was so early in the week i
thought it was wednesday or thursday
so you do have a work session scheduled
for tomorrow at 9 30 and you could use
that for this purpose if you wanted to
uh representative edwards what's your
what's your desire
but he might have stepped away
all right i'm here i'm sorry i just
i've been muting myself so that i don't
uh
so i can resist the temptation just
burst in
so um what i think we maybe ought to do
is to vote on the one independent
section
that represents moving 254
over into hb2 go ahead and vote on that
now and then if that's
done then the then the decision to maybe
retain hb
254 gets to be clear if we took those
two steps today
and then we deferred the rest of this
work to what mr ripple suggested
i i think we'd have more locked down
a little bit earlier all right so
this would be that's amendment 0.937
i'll pitch b2
what we had for the first part i thought
was 0.926
you're right i'm sorry it's 0.926 all
right
you want to pull it up just so again
we're looking at it
yes
[Music]
so so if you would scroll down i'd i'd
be willing to make a motion that we
uh accept amendment zero nine
two six i just wanna verify that this is
yes okay
that's enough um okay so representative
edwards moves
amendment zero nine two six is there a
second
can i put you down as a second
second second norgrin here northern
seconds
thank you
okay further discussion
seeing none call a role for adopting
uh amendment 0926 to hb2
representative edwards yes
represent earth yes representative
weiler votes yes representative bean
yes representative walner yes
representative nordgren yes
representative rogers yes
and the vote is seven to zero okay so
we're done with that
portion for now mr chairman and uh
we've had some for
mr ripple and you can tell him when
we'll
come to the vote on the rest of them
so so mr ripple it thank you thank you
representative weiler and representative
walner nordren
and at all for taking lead on that um
but so mr ripple okay
if there it felt to me like you had a
lot of notes
and maybe a couple of them might be a
little confusing
does it is does it feel to you like you
really need
all morning and maybe even some
afternoon to
to get ols working on it is it is it
possible
possible to come back tomorrow with it
i think you could i think you could come
back tomorrow um if i got a little
clarification on a couple of the items
today okay can i float another idea
could could we like
vote out of an hb2 placeholder
and and put it in there to where
we could work for several days without
worrying
that we get this language exactly the
way we want
and then the placeholder if it gets
sucked in and over to
senate the senate then we would have
independent separate language to hand
them to fill in the blank
we may not be able to do that
so are you suggesting incorporating
what's been discussed today as is but
working
at some later date to come up with
revised language
that that seems like an option to
consider
just because i i do want to be able to
declare
we're done at some point and i don't
want
the fact that we need to declare
ourselves as being done
to pressure us to making you know
an ill-fought-out decision
so i'm looking for alternatives to buy
us a little time without
killing our deadline representative
wallner do you
do you have an idea there yeah i mean
we've got 254
has passed okay so that the first part
of it
then the next part i think it's we've
just got a few
um just a few changes i don't think it's
really i don't think it's like we have
rewritten
the whole the whole rsa i mean i don't
think we've
rewritten the whole statute here i think
we've i think we've just got a few
changes and it seems like coming back
tomorrow morning i think ols
could probably get this ready for us
um i certainly wouldn't i mean i think
the house
i think it's good for the house to have
a position when we get over to the
senate we can be flexible i mean
obviously
the senate is going to get a lot more
information people are going to come in
people are going to like it people
aren't going to like it people
want to be on the commission people went
off the commission i mean you know
what's going to happen
our emails are filled tonight but
i think we should we need something and
i think we did the work this afternoon
so that's just my suggestion i i love
your suggestion
and i'll i'll put away my concern
knowing that mr ripple can work with ols
on the remaining pieces to clean it up
and then uh so but
because ols will need the morning
we we probably need to get back together
in the afternoon
does do people have conflicts or do they
have uh the
their afternoons free because if their
afternoons are free i'd like to
uh you know go ahead and we have to call
the meeting in the session at 9 30 and
then we can recess to one
or something like that if no one has a
schedule conflict
yeah i had warning in morning conflicts
at uh eight o'clock with the governor
and then
9 15 probably with the
speaker so
how about one o'clock is one is the
afternoon clear for you sir it is it is
one o'clock
representative nordgren well i was just
going to ask
kevin how long it would take
it this foreign not sure it would take
that long
i guess thank you yeah i don't think it
would take that long i think if you
wanted to meet at 9 30 tomorrow we would
have everything ready by then easily
if there are other reasons to not meet
in the morning like scheduled conflicts
that's another story but we could have
it by 9 30.
so we're going to have to start this
meeting at 9
30. that that's what's in the calendar
we'll start it at 9 30 if ols can
support us that quick
great we'll knock it out if they if ols
isn't ready
then we'll have to recess until a
reasonable time in the afternoon
all right i'm i've got this
207 i'm not sure what that is 915 and
207 but
i'll find out when i get there maybe
i'll be there by 9 30.
i'll be up and conquered on my computer
up there
and really the only thing i needed
clarification on was i wasn't sure there
was any resolution about taking out
waypoint by name or the disabilities
rights center by name
i think representative weiler made a
convincing case to leave him in
because they're leaning forward in the
foxhole and they're ready to engage
getting those appointments um
say again we'll all blanks be removed
well those will be taken care of when um
house bill 2 was strung together so
they'll reference the appropriate
sections
okay thank you so in that way
point area mr ripple would
you add another line
never mind i'm going to leave that wrong
all right
well great so we've had we have a game
plan you're going to try to get it
cleaned up
get it through ols we'll meet at 9 30 if
it's ready we can talk about it
and then if it's not we can recess for
the amount of time that's needed
representative nordgren so
do you anticipate a full vote on the
budget we've prepared tomorrow or what's
the end game for finishing our work
well as i i think the uh
the last thing that we really need to
vote on is hb
254 as as uh i talked to mr ripple
we we don't need to vote on an entire
budget
because with all the components that we
have voted on
he can piece it together and that's and
that's what our budget proposal is
did i hear you right mr ripple that's
correct you voted on all the individual
components
with the exception of the sununu center
and with with the exception of the house
bill one side of the sununu center which
is what i was going to bring up next
why don't you bring up house bill one
side of the issue now
okay
now my understanding was that along with
the
closure of the sununu center and the
adoption of the house bill 2 amendments
you would also be zeroing out the budget
for this nunu center in 23
and that's what this represents
so move
second
all right uh is there further discussion
uh not seeing any further discussion uh
mr chair would you or mr clerk would you
call a roll
representative earth yes representative
weiler votes yes representative bean
yes representative walner yes
representative nordroom
yes representative rogers
yes representative edwards yes
mr chair of the voter 7-0 all right
thank you
okay so
so i think we're ready to uh take up hb
um and given what we just did with house
bill 2.
i i think the uh the idea here is that
we probably ought to retain 254
so that we have a vehicle to react with
later should we need one um
[Music]
okay so um with that i would accept
a motion to retain house bill 254
in finance you have a question mr german
yes so we voted didn't we vote to otp
yesterday so
can we now come back and just say we're
changing our mind we're going to retain
it
no we didn't vote uh otp on 254 i don't
think
we voted in 600. okay but i make a
motion to retain
hb 254 is there a second
second i'll second it seconded
uh it's first and second is are there
any further discussion
representative norgren are you okay you
were messing with your monitor did you
okay you're okay so there not being any
further discussion
uh with the clerk call a roll on the
motion to retain
house bill 254
representative earth yes representative
weiler votes yes representative bean
yes representative
yes representative yes
representative rogers yes
representative edwards yes
voter 7-0
okay good okay
so other than the sununu center house
bill 2
we're we're done is that right mr ripple
that's correct so everyone on the
committee recheck your notes
because i a couple times i thought i had
a complete list and people have
uh shaken me and corrected me so
representative erf
didn't you say you were doing something
with representative uh rogers
oh i i am i'm just i'm just trying to
tie this up okay so
uh representative walner did you have
yes i just wondered if i could ask kevin
um to remind me what kind of documents
will
the division be getting and when when do
you think we might be able to get them
about all of our decisions what
the piece that we will probably take to
finance
the full finance committee
well as usual um full finance exec
session the chair of each division will
be presenting two things what we call
the detailed change sheet
showing all of the differences between
the governor's recommended budget and
the division's recommended budget
in house bill and then also a packet of
house
bill 2 amendments that typically is
provided to the chair
in advance so they can work their way
through those documents and get ready
for the presentation
i don't know that the full committee
typically receives it before the day of
the exec
though
so go ahead follow up
did you have one representative norgren
so we wouldn't be able to receive the
documents and copy them
and have them in front of us as we
listen to the presentations
from each division they would be
available the day of the exec session
um i don't is the question will you get
hard copies
yeah um i'm not sure
i'd probably not
okay are we talking about basically two
sheets of paper though
we're talking about closets we're
talking about a lot of paper
the detail change sheet is typically at
least a couple of pages long
and the house bill 2 amendment packet
will contain
the 10 or so amendments that you passed
previously as well as the
sununu center amendments
plus all the other divisions when we get
together with them
yes everything for the other divisions
too
so and that's the standard way of
working historically
yes representative wallner
i i i guess this is the request of you
chairman edwards
i wondered if um what kevin just said
was that you will receive
a detailed change report
before we go into the exec session
and i'm wondering if you would be
willing to share it with
um the other members of the division so
that we have it in front of us
as we're and and maybe have it
in front of us a night before so we can
kind of re
remember what all the all the things
that we did
right and that's obviously a chairman's
decision
i i i would like to to say that um
by now i i hope you think that i'm
fairly transparent and i want to get the
information out earlier rather than
later
and i saw my i'm predisposed to doing
that
there's a historical reason that seems
to not be
the way it's done so i'd like to learn
why
that is so that i know what decision i'm
making but
i'm generally predisposed to sharing
what i know
so will you take that as an answer for
now
yes i and to tell you the truth i didn't
even remember that we
didn't share them in the past
but only that that only the chair of the
division had it
i i didn't realize that representative
wilder's waving
yes sir generally we'll get you know
however many pages will be like
a paragraph or two janet will prepare
it'll be division one glove of about
division two bubbles
it'll show the vote from the division
and the recommendation from the division
and it'll have
you know a paragraph of what each
amendment's about
so generally that's what everybody sees
you know if you need more detail it's up
to what the chairman wants to provide
you but
generally that's what we all see
especially because it's going to be a
huge stack
and so it'll it'll still go on for three
or four pages with the number of
amendments we've got in each division so
three or four pages with a paragraph
probably for each what each
amendment's about i think janet does
that
so yeah we'll still get that
see it in their place
okay all right so i think we can
go to the next topic um representative
rogers put a lot of work
into preparing to talk to us about her
hb1
proposal related to family planning
and um i i
i would like to offer her an opportunity
to
share with us what she
has come to want to propose
representative rogers
as i said to you earlier in an email i
think we've moved on from there
it's clear to me how you and the
majority of the division feels about
this so i don't want to waste anyone's
time
all right it's your it's your call
on whether you present your proposal or
not
i i would just say that
our feelings don't matter in this case
it's the proper polite thing to do to
give you an
opportunity to present all the work that
you did
and i i'm i'm prepared to listen to what
you had to say
um but it like i said it's your choice
and uh i want to i want you to know that
whatever your choice is we support it
um i'm not prone to be a kamikaze for no
reason i know how the vote will turn out
so i don't think it's my choice to waste
my time nor yours
all right well um so with that
are there any final comments for the
good of the committee
okay so i think uh what we're ready to
go into adjournment until 9 30 tomorrow
morning
with the game plan that if we can uh
work through
the changes to the hb2 around the sununu
center we'll
we'll knock it out starting at 9 30
and if not we'll reschedule to the
afternoon to buy time for ols
so uh with that uh we're in adjournment
thank you
thank you thank you